-It is so awesome to have you
on the show
just because, you know,
we're big fans.
You've been on the show
a bunch of times,
but today is actually
your record is out!
-It's out.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
The odds of us seeing --
I'm so happy to witness this.
-I'm honored to see you
the day of.
-Yeah!
-It's a good luck charm, maybe.
-Yes, it is!
-Yeah.
-It's finally out.
Let's look at it right here.
"Humble Quest."
-That's her.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Alright.
I want to talk about the title.
I want to talk about the photo.
What's the photo?
How'd you decide on this cover?
-Well, it was the last setup
of the day
and it was in this
like high school basement gym.
And so I was like, "Yeah,
I guess we'll do it,
if it's here."
But it was heated.
-So this is just a pool
in a high school
and you jumped in?
-Yeah. I mean, they let me in.
[ Laughter ]
-No, yeah. You didn't break in.
Yeah, you didn't break, yeah.
-No.
But it actually, it just ended
up being one of my favorites
because it wasn't like overdone
and my hair's wet
and it felt kind of like
baptismal, in a way.
So it fit the vibe
of the music, So.
-And "Humble Quest,"
which is the name of the album.
What does that mean,
humble quest?
-Well, I feel like
the last two years
were probably humbling
for all humans,
just not having jobs
or just not having a purpose.
And I had my son at the very
beginning of the pandemic,
so that cut me down
a little bit, too.
I had kind of a rough
like delivery and so,
yeah, having my son
and then having touring canceled
for two years was just like
I'm celebrating my baby,
but I can't like share him
with anybody
because we're quarantining
and then I couldn't tour.
So it was just like
a really grounding experience,
learning that like --
Like I love what I do.
I've been doing music
since I was ten,
but I put so much
of my worth in it
and I think the last two years
taught me that
like I can love what I do,
but I don't have to do it
to feel loved,
if that makes sense.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Good for you.
You got through it.
You got through it
and you have a beautiful baby.
-Yes.
-Beautiful baby boy.
And I actually love,
on one of the tracks,
I think it's "Hummingbird,"
maybe...
-Yeah.
-...he's on.
He says, "Mama."
-Yeah.
-It's very cute.
It's awesome.
-I actually wrote "Hummingbird"
the day I found out
I was having my son back in 2019
and then the pandemic hit,
I had him, and then, by the time
I was recording this record,
my son was starting to talk.
And so I got a little iPhone
voice recording
of him saying "Mama," and so
Greg Kurstin, my producer,
put it at the top of that song.
It's actually the only feature
on the record, is my son.
[ Laughter ]
-Featuring, yeah.
He got a feature credit, yeah.
-Yeah.
-The Grammys are next weekend.
You're nominated for two awards.
Congratulations on that.
-Thanks.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You meet a lot of people.
You've done collaborations
with everyone cool.
I mean, gosh,
you're just amazing already,
your career,
and you're still so young.
But Dolly, just to say,
just to start there.
Taylor.
But I was like,
is there anyone that really like
blows your mind
and you freak out
and you fangirl out?
-I feel like twice in my life
I've been starstruck
by somebody and like one --
Well, actually three.
One was Dolly,
the other was Elton John,
like meeting him, and then --
-[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
-I was --
And Jimothy Fallon.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
-Starstruck, yes.
-My God! Okay.
-The four people.
-[Both] Yeah.
-But no. Okay.
The fourth would be
I was at this Beatles
documentary party
at Henson Studios in L.A.
a couple of months ago
and I was leaving early
because that's like my move
-[ Laughs ]
-and I saw Amy Poehler doing
the exact same thing.
[ Awws and laughter ]
And I had a couple
margaritas in me,
but I never do this,
but I was like,
"I will regret if I don't go
up to her and just say like
how much she means to me."
And especially like just
growing up watching "SNL"
with you guys on it
and just how much she means
to me as a woman who is funny.
And I go over to her
and she's so sweet
like I'm sure you know
because you know her.
-She's the greatest.
-But I was just like bawling,
and I was like,
"I know you don't know who I am,
but I'm such a huge fan of yours
and thank you,
blah, blah, blah."
And she was like,
"I know who you are."
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Yeah,
you're Maren Morris.
I mean, you're pretty famous."
Here's a picture
of you guys together.
-Yeah.
[ Awws and applause ]
-I look like I need
to be sedated.
[ Laughter ]
-Amy is the best.
-Yeah, she is.
-She's a good one.
-Someone sedate this girl
that is bothering Amy Poehler.
Yeah. I have tears in my eyes
in the photo.
-Yeah, good.
"Humble Quest" -- Congrats.
It's record day.
I'm so happy it's out.
Everyone download it,
whatever you got to do.
Buy this album.
And you're actually going
on tour this summer.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's all happening, bud.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thanks.
I'm playing Radio City, so.
-You are coming.
-I'll be across the way.
-I'm there! I'm so there.
-Alright.
-I will be onstage if you want.
I love you.
[ Laughter ]
What song are you doing
for us tonight?
I'm going to do my song
"Circles Around This Town," so.
-There you go.
I'm so happy you're here.
We love you.
Maren Morris, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Congrats. "Humble Quest"
is out right now!